welcome to the program it didn't take
long took about little over ten months
into Donald Trump's presidency but
officially now Donald Trump's FCC is
going to try to kill net neutrality and
for years I've been telling you that if
we want to think about the most
important macro political issues no
matter what micro issue is most
important to you we have to be thinking
about money and politics and that really
has three components right one is how
elections are financed and the specifics
of laws like citizens united number two
is media coverage of politics which
rectly relates to money in politics or
it's sort of a subsection of that and
number three is net neutrality which
somewhat could even the playing field in
order to have a less disadvantageous
situation to the average Internet user
and news consumer and purveyor of
independent media like the David Pakman
show and we knew that when Donald Trump
selected Ajit pi a former lawyer for
Verizon to run the FCC we knew that
eventually they would go for a full-out
attempt at killing net neutrality
regulations that were passed during
President Obama's presidency and the
time has come and they're moving ahead
with that and left alone it's going to
happen right there's really no other way
to say it it will be a three to two vote
in favor of scrapping net neutrality
left untouched there is no question
about that whatsoever and if and when
these rules go go away and it
increasingly seems that it's a matter of
when rather than if although I will
address that a little bit later on in
the program terrible things are going to
happen internet service providers will
be able to create internet slow lanes
and fast lanes they can't do that now
based on the regulations that were
passed under President Obama and it is a
hugely anti-democratic thing to have
these internet slow lanes and fast lanes
created big service providers like
Netflix for example could be charged way
more if they want internet customers to
have fast access to their platform so
for example Time Warner
owns HBO and Time Warner is also a cable
and internet provider Time Warner knows
that some people are choosing Netflix
over HBO or Netflix through the internet
instead of having cable TV at all right
Netflix is connected to cord cutting and
Time Warner doesn't want people cutting
their cable cord so what Time Warner
could do if net neutrality is repealed
is number one
slow down access to Netflix to make it
more annoying to the end user which
might make some people say you know what
I don't want to deal with pixelated
images and rebuffering when watching
Netflix
I guess maybe instead I'll get cable or
buy HBO or something like that and
number two what Time Warner can do or
could do will be able to do if and when
net neutrality is repealed is that they
can say to Netflix hey we'll give your
customers access to Netflix as smoothly
as we give our customers access to HBO
but you've got to pay us a huge amount
of money to get Netflix functioning at
normal speed and more than likely
Netflix would then increase its rates
and you would end up paying for that
additional expense that is levied by
Time Warner or whoever it is that wants
to do it it will be passed along to you
and thus it will be the consumer who
ends up paying more to maintain the same
sometimes mediocre access to some of
these content platforms that you like
and might even be taken for granted at
this time so absolute and total disaster
and I don't even have to mention by the
way when you look at the connections
between internet service providers and
news media Comcast ownership of MSNBC
pick your example right whatever example
you want to talk about I don't even have
to get into how this would be disastrous
potentially for purveyors of independent
media like the david pakman show and so
many others that my guess is many of the
people in our audience value and
understand the importance of you could
have bundled websites if you've ever
tried to access Wi-Fi on an airplane you
might see that you might get for $5.00
you can get inflight Wi-Fi to check your
email
but for $10 you can go to social media
websites like Facebook and Twitter and
if you pay $15 for flight in-flight
Wi-Fi during your flight you can watch
videos on YouTube or access your Netflix
account for example right those aren't
exact prices but that's the idea but hey
you're on an airplane it's a little bit
of a different situation it's just a few
hours it's not your day-to-day
interaction with the internet that could
become the internet status quo if net
neutrality regulations are repealed and
the even even sicker part of it is that
consumers want net neutrality or most
consumers who might not understand
net net neutrality by that name if you
ask them are you in favor of or against
this provision that is part of net
neutrality or that provision
overwhelmingly consumers are in favor of
this
it is huge businesses and lobbyists that
are against net neutrality regulations a
ton of Pro net neutrality comments have
flooded into the FCC and the FCC is
effectively ignoring them moving forward
with this proposal to repeal net
neutrality and the FCC is also citing
that there have been tons of consumer
comments against net neutrality but it
increasingly appears that a huge portion
of the so-called
consumer comments in opposition to net
neutral neutrality regulations were fake
just straight-up fake there's a data
scientist named Jeff Cao who has used
language processing techniques to
analyze all of the so-called anti net
neutrality comments that were received
and he has determined that at least 1.3
million of them were straight-up fake
and that endless more commands are
suspicious based on the language that
was there they appear appear to have
been sort of a combination of computer
generated astroturf and possibly even
more mischievous type of activity so do
not be tricked right the I guess there's
really no better word than the one I use
the astroturf around anti net neutrality
is mostly bogus case in point
go to our YouTube channel and check out
this interview I did years ago with a
woman named Crystal High who
pitched to us as a great speaker on net
neutrality and it turned out that she
was actually a paid shill for the Corp
for the cable industry lobby and I
called her out during the interview it's
an extraordinary thing that happens
crystal high is her name you can check
that out and just to get a sense of the
depths and an extent to which we are
seeing anti net neutrality astroturf but
back to the present situation this is an
emergency crisis situation what can you
do I don't know I don't want to be naive
I don't know that we can really do
anything and I don't know that that what
I'm about to tell you will change the
outcome of this attempted net neutrality
repeal but you can go to battle for the
Netcom they have a form you can fill out
that will send a letter to your
representatives telling them that you
object to this that you were against
this I encourage you to also go to who
is my representative dot-com or net I
never remember put in your information
and call every single one of the elected
officials that is listed for you members
of the House of Representatives senator
if you want to call the governor I want
to call your local state Rep or state
senator by all means do it and then also
on December 7th that are gonna be
protests outside of Verizon stores and
you can go to Verizon protests calm to
find out more about that this is bad
this is really really bad and this is a
systemic threat to so many forms of of
media of speech and it is yet again
going along with we're going to talk
about taxes next in conjunction with how
the Trump Republican tax plan is a major
handout to the richest and to
corporations the attempted repeal and
what might be the successful repeal of
net neutrality is exactly the same thing
a handout to particularly corporations
and also to the rich people in control
of those could those corporations as a
way to make even more money off of you
the average person so battle for the
Netcom and Verizon protests dot-com the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we our viewers
ported independent media you can use the
coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership